we still don't know a lot about the new
Titans in titanfall too but a new
trailer has showed off some of what we
can expect from the new mex respawn
announced today that it plans to
showcase the three remaining Titans over
the next several days I unen scourge
were playable during the recent
technical test while the sword-wielding
Ronan was one of the early highlights
when titanfall 2 was first announced
North Star Legion in town have remained
question marks until now but you can get
a quick peek at them and a new trailer
ahead of their impending unveilings the
titanfall 2 blog also shared some fairly
vague descriptions of each Titan to give
you a better sense of what they bring to
the table the blog reads North Star is a
master of both flight and precision
kills Legion utilizes an assortment of
ballistic abilities focusing on defense
and control and tone is about accurately
laying waste to enemies both efficiently
and explosively respawn also announced
today that the angel city map a map from
the original titanfall will be titanfall
tues first dlc release those who
pre-order the game will receive three
days of early access to the map after
that it will be free for all players as
respawn and EA have said that all
titanfall 2 DLC will be free titanfall 2
is slated for release on pc playstation
4 and xbox one on october 28 which titan
are you most looking forward to let me
know in the comments below and for more
on titanfall stay tuned to gamespot